all right here's the story from the
Daily Mail Pfizer admits engineering
coveted mutants in lab studies to ensure
its antiviral drug works on new variants
but Pharma giant insists tests were not
gain of function and did not pose risk
to the public I love this story because
like we constantly hear this where it's
like you know the analogy I give is you
know Dr fauci is there a door on the
building of the niaid no there is no
door we have no door we have a pothole
with a large wooden object and there is
a mechanic mechanical device you twist
which causes it to unlatch and open on
hinges and you're like bro you're
describing a door they just play this
game where they're like I didn't jaywalk
I just crossed the street not in the
crosswalk it's like you're describing
literally the thing so Pfizer in
response presumably to project Veritas
released a statement at 8 pm on Friday
look at this Friday January 27th 8 PM
you know we did a show that day but like
we didn't see this message come out
literally the moment we go live because
we we do pre-production about an hour
before
but we're gonna make sure we get this
story front and center on Monday
so that nobody forgets they try to
memory hold us let me read for you what
they say because uh it'll make you laugh
allegations have recently been made is
their statement related to gain of
function and directed Evolution research
at Pfizer and the company would like to
set the record straight
the next paragraph you're about to hear
is just patter to like make you not want
to read it they say in the ongoing
development of the Pfizer bio and Tech
covid-19 vaccine Pfizer has not
conducted gain a function or directed
Evolution research working with
collaborators we have conducted research
where the original SARS covet 2 virus
has been used to express the spike
protein from new variants of concern
this work is undertaken once a new
variant of concern has been identified
by public health authorities This
research provides a way for us to
rapidly assess the ability of an
existing vaccine to induce antibodies
that neutralize a newly identified
variant of concern we then make the data
available through peer-reviewed
scientific journals and use it as one of
the steps to determine whether a vaccine
update is required
okay so wait
you you get the new variance then you
test it see if you need to update makes
sense they add
in addition to meet U.S and Global
regulatory requirements for our oral
treatment Pax livid Pfizer undertakes in
vitro work EG in a laboratory culture
dish to identify potential resistance
mutations to nirma travel trailver one
of pax Levitt's two components with a
naturally evolving virus that is
important to routinely assess the
activity of an antiviral most of the
work is conducted using computer
simulations or of or mutations of the
main protease a non-infectious part of
the virus you see at this point I'm
reading it like they're not saying
they're engineering anything they're
then going to say in a limited number of
cases when a full virus does not contain
any known gain of function mutations
such virus may be engineered to enable
the assessment of antiviral activity in
cells okay
now they're just trying to play a legal
game with me let's just break that
sentence down to try and understand it
in in a limited number of cases when a
full virus does not contain any known
gain of function mutations
such virus may be engineered to enable
the assessment of antiviral activity in
cells what they're saying is when they
engineer the cell they need it to
express mutations like they said they
were checking for so that they can see
if their antiviral works that to me fine
don't call it gain of function call it
engineering like they did so covid's
actually engineering such a virus as
they've stated to assess antiviral
activity okay there you go
sorry
engineering but oh yeah Pfizer Pfizer
sorry yeah so Pfizer we're saying in
this they admit to engineering certain
viruses they said and they have to check
and see if it works right right it's not
getting a function or directed Evolution
it's engineering what I I want to know
this is the game they play you're right
Jim because when I read this I also
started to fall asleep after especially
after the second paragraph where they're
like let us be clear about what we did
we did not do it was the first the way
they start up the first thing but when
they say that they they've conducted
research where the original SARS Cove 2
let me get this
blow this image up here
has been used to express the Sprite the
spike protein from new variants so the
original SARS cov2 virus has been used
to express the spike protein from new
variants what does that mean that that
just the use of us to express a protein
in another variant well no it just
sounds like what they're saying is
when there's a new variant discovered
they take it and then they
put it in a dish and like grow it so
they can have this micronism that that
doesn't sound like gain of function or
anything like that it's the bottom it's
the middle part of the third pair well
second paragraph where they're like and
in a limited number of cases if the
virus does not contain any known gain of
funky mutations such a virus may be
engineered it sounds like they're saying
engineered to have gain of function
mutations it does sound like they're
saying that I think they are saying that
but you had uh you had fauci saying for
a while that they weren't doing gain of
function and then it was clear that the
research that was being funded was gain
of function research it says gain of
function on the research documents
that's what it says and and Rand Paul is
like Dr fauci this this document is
yours and it says gain of function
research no we did not do it it says
right here gain function I didn't do it
okay man I just and you can see why they
would think it's a good idea right you
can see why they would think like okay
we're gonna do research we're gonna
figure out you know we're gonna we're
gonna make the virus worse so that we
can test our drugs and whatever else you
can see why they think it's a good idea
but that doesn't make it
um untrue that they're doing it I
disagree I I think the potential
mutations of a virus have to be
what is this let's say there's there's a
million potential mutations to the virus
why would they mutate and be like if we
muted it this way we can make a vaccine
for it this way it's like oh so one of a
million chance you make money off that
it doesn't make sense to me I don't know
to me it sounds like the quintessential
cya they just spent a whole paragraph
telling us they're not doing something
and just slip the sentence in there
saying it's like we're doing it
I was saying before the show to you Matt
that like I think the uh maybe even have
like you know immunity from the CIA is
like go you're gonna have to lie on this
one and you've got all retroactive
immunity if it comes out that you were
lying in the future so I mean is public
information that Pfizer's got immunity I
mean and the reason they have immunity
is because our politicians aren't the
one running the show here guys and you
guys know that the people that are fun
in their campaigns are the ones running
their show and who's at the top of that
food chain Pfizer in the pharmacy just
massive people to print the money
basically who's making the money where's
the money coming from because those are
the people that are divvying out like
the federal decides who gets the loans
first right so you've got
um maybe a company that might sound like
black
Croc and I just said random word I
thought of and they get Federal Reserve
loans just pass right along to them to
buy up whatever they want companies like
these then uh you know I think we'll
invest in packs and super Pacs allowing
politicians to get elected I don't know
if um if overturning citizens united
ruling would actually change this it
might I'd be interested to hear what
people thought about that you guys are
familiar with citizens united yeah yeah
basically super Pacs as long as as long
as they don't collude with the candidate
they can they can you can donate an
infinite number of money and then they
can say whatever they want so what ends
up happening is you get big corporations
they'll go to the the candidate and say
are you the guy who's going to help our
very important research save America
because we're looking to donate a lot to
help that happen and then the candidate
will be like well I don't know nothing
about that but rest assured I'm a big
fan of Pfizer and them helping would
sure would be great if I won and they go
we get it they then go to super I can
say here's 500 million dollars we want
him Super PAC can run a campaign for
somebody you know you have to be
involved in it they're going to make you
win well Biden is planning to completely
increase the medical induct industrial
complex as part of the cancer moonshot
plan
you know their funding so they're going
to put so much money in to create
Federal
um like basically a
federally funded federally Affiliated
medical research situation wow that
sounds like a good idea I guess
disturbing very disturbing yeah but
that's that's like part of their big
plan they're going to increase that
portion of the federal government get a
whole bunch of researchers on there to
do you know more stuff like this
um all in the idea that they're going to
cure cancer I wonder how much cancer
they make in Labs you know that they're
then going to try and cure it yeah well
I mean high acidity lymphatic system can
cause the cells to duplicate at a rapid
pace which a lot of scientists call
cancer like if you don't alkalize your
your lymphatic system
you can feed people sugar and keep
making medicine and then you're doubling
down on the profit because not only are
they buying your food they're buying
your medicine I can't stand it I think
that there's some value for Pfizer to be
working on uh uh I guess you'd call it
gain a function in simulations and
computer simulations like yeah
billions of potential viral outcomes and
then millions and billions of potential
digital
you know cures of viruses in a computer
keep it in the computer because outside
you know they can leak they can leak
viruses can leak you create something
that you're afraid of becoming reality
you just created the thing that you were
afraid of becoming reality so I don't
know but I mean I think they're doing it
personally I think they're just doing it
for profit I think that companies
because they're allowed to if someone's
allowed to do something assume that
they're going to that if they're allowed
to make a virus and and a medicine for
it and profit off that medicine why
would they not well and once a once that
kind of technology or something like
that is created it will be used it's
just a matter of time the for-profit
aspect of it is is absolutely I mean
it's it's terrifying it's not
it's unethical it's a profit off of a
meta
I don't know people profit off of food
they profit off of food the food
industry is for profits so look man I've
never been all about laissez-faire
capitalism like Luke is you know he
likes to come on and he just talks about
how capitalism or free market solves
everything and this is corporatism and
things like that and the government
actually intervenes to help major
corporations win it's not really
capitalism but I genuinely believe that
if you have completely unrestricted
markets you're going to get seed oils
like this is my shout out to Luke or
Caskey the way I change is you're not
here to defend yourself but too bad
unrestrained capitalism a company is
going to say look no one cares about
seed oils only these these weirdos like
Luke gradkowski are complaining about
seed oils and they're cheaper use those
but and then everyone's gonna start
eating them and if they get sick they're
not going to know why and there's not
going to be anything they're not gonna
they're gonna keep buying these products
um what really concerns me is the drug
dealers that are making money off this
system like Pfizer is a company that
deals drugs I mean you might use a
different term they sell drugs to people
but like the the tobacco industry used
to have commercials for kids they would
Target kids with Joe Camel and like they
want you to start early and that was the
Congress had to step in because the you
know unrestricted capitalism yeah you're
right about the drugs though and if you
look at the data the number of kids and
teens that are on psych meds
um is incredibly High and a lot of the
kids that are on psych meds are like
vulnerable kids like kids in foster care
a lot of boys are on psych meds and a
lot of these kids are on medications
that are not approved for their age
group and they're on multiple drug
cocktails that are not approved for
their age group as well I just want to
say stink bugs are lucky lucky they're
kind of cute and doofy they're not cute
I think they're they're tremendous
they're creepy they're not creepy
they're just like they they clap you
know that I don't like them they clap I
did it I I don't kill them but I also
don't like them you kill them they make
a stinky smell I don't want anything he
was he was on my monitor but uh they
clap I'm not even kidding I recorded a
segment and then I was done and I looked
up and there's a stink bug just going
like this like I'm like why is it what
is that like some kind of mating call
probably right I mean they were just
like you know you complain about Joe
Biden it's so good they danced too you
watch them they'll like walk sideways
and then walk sideways and then keep
doing and like turn and shake and stuff
well as far as these uh pharmaceutical
companies go
this is saying to me how incentivized
doctors are to prescribe a certain
medication I was when I was in the
military I was a combat medic so I was
an infantry medic and the first job I
got when I got out of the military I was
working at a hospital and these
pharmaceutical reps would come in and
whine and die in these doctors and
provide all of us even us Medics you
know free lunches and such and uh and
it's just the same to me how
incentivized these doctors are to sell
those specific products and as far as
the packs go they may not be able to
deal directly with a with a candidate
but everybody knows you know if it's two
or three people removed they get a hold
of these candidates and I'm when Matt
Gates was on the show just a uh just a
few days ago he told you guys he said
the first thing you do when you become a
congressman when you get to DC is you
sit down at the table with the people
who are the leaders in the industry that
you want to be a commit on a committee
of and uh and and that just shows you
right there it proves to you how corrupt
politics are to let you know that these
politicians that we get pissed off at
and that we blame for all of these
problems they're not the ones running
the show it's these lobbyists and uh and
these packs in the pharmaceutical
industry I mean those guys are at the
top of the top of that food chain it's a
lot of companies the military industrial
complex absolutely Lockheed you got
Boeing you got Halliburton I mean the
list goes on Northrop what you were
saying too about
um hospitals and pharmaceutical reps at
when I finished College I worked for a
uh like a small medical office and I was
like doing Insurance paperwork that was
my job but these pharmaceutical reps
would come in like almost every day and
they would bring lunch for the entire
office and they'd just like spill sample
cases full of their drugs all over the
place and it's so weird you're right
like they used to Target kids with
tobacco advertising and now like anytime
you watch TV there's half a dozen drug
advertisements and you listen to the
list and my son and I will joke about it
he'll be like oh this drug for
depression Mom it cures your depression
but you might have increased thoughts of
suicide and it's like oh okay isn't that
the opposite of what's supposed to do
and you listen to it and it's like this
will help you lose weight but you you
might want to kill yourself or or
sleeping drugs and it says like you may
forget that you got up and drove your
car while you were on this drug so be
careful with that and why are we seeing
all of these
um advertisements for major
pharmaceutical drugs that can make you
think you're sleeping while actually
you're driving your car the best thing
is uh when they don't actually tell you
what the drug does right and they never
do they're like ask your doctor and
you're like about what yeah I I remember
saying commercial I can't remember y'all
probably seen commercials like this
where it's like an old guy and he's like
looking sad and it's like the color's
gray and it's like feeling down maybe
Clovis stall is right for you and then
he's smiling and then he's like walking
through a park and it's like ask your
doctor today about clove vessel no I
don't know what you're selling me yeah
like the drug domains are so bizarre
like oh
it's a remedy the side effects from this
pill and then you need another pill to
remedy the side effects from that pill
and it just goes on and on and on and
that's why they created pill boxes this
one makes the pain go away but also
makes you want to die this one makes you
not want to die but could also make you
think about wanting to die so then you
have this one here that actually makes
you forget what's going on so that you
don't remember wanting to that side
effect it might cause pain so original
pill might have to double your
prescription you know I think when the
the oxycodone epidemic in the 90s late
90s this is the oxy this is the far this
is what you call the what would you call
it the what kind of drug is that it was
like an opiate I remember actually I was
trying to I was trying to buy weed and
uh the guy didn't have any weed and he
was like oh here take this and it wasn't
it was an oxycontin and I was I was out
for like two days I was look at that and
then you had no idea what it was you
took it no yeah I was an idiot I was an
idiot obviously yeah don't do that
nobody else should ever do that
especially with fentanyl people have
been dying from overdosing on fentanyl
that they think is like uh get the whole
fentanyl thing isn't it a prescription
drug like how did it get in all the
street drugs like how did this happen
prescription and Street China I'll tell
you so in 2012 it is I had a vasectomy
in 2012. and first time I ever took any
kind of painkiller so they gave me
Percocet and Vicodin oh man that's a lot
of painkillers that's a lot of
painkillers
powerful stuff I took two
and I flushed them down the toilet and
the reason I flushed them down the
toilet is because it was like the best
drunkness you've ever had without the
hangover and I was like this is
dangerous so I just I had to flush them
down the toilet and it's in the American
Water Supply because people are flushing
them down
might get filtered out but I I in 2014 I
had a kidney stone
and there's something they can do for
you I mean if it's like really bad you
might get surgery but it wasn't really
that bad it just it hurts and also
people don't understand let me tell you
guys it's it's inside your body it's not
like you know you're going to the
bathroom one day and you're like there's
something jammed up in you know my my
schlong or something you're you're at
the doctors and it I'm like it's either
appendicitis or like they thought it was
appendicitis and then I went in like
pain in my abdomen and they're like yeah
it's your kidneys release like a small
rock and they're like nothing we can do
about it here's a bottle of pills and I
took one and you're you nailed it feel
awesome and and I never took another one
you wrote a song about it at least
that's one of the songs you were telling
me about it was that uh the guy
searching for the the fix at least that
was one that was written a long time
before that was wild but this is this is
uh like the feeling you get from it was
so intense that I did same thing you did
yeah I didn't push on the toilet I just
threw it away but the point is that so I
flush it down the toilet and I just took
Motrin and guess what I was absolutely
fine that's all I needed so these
doctors they're just pushing this
medication just shoving it down your
throat well it's not only the medication
it's surgery it's like at one point I
hurt my back like after my son was born
and I saw two doctors and they were like
you need back surgery and I was like no
no I do not need back surgery look at
Hulk Hogan he's paralyzing though right
yeah we were just talking about it
before the show I had a doctor I went in
because I was having trouble sleeping
and she prescribed me sleeping pills
which then gave me nightmares and I also
couldn't sleep and then I bought new
pillows like I literally bought new
pillows and I didn't have an issue ever
like ever after that you know the reason
I brought up the opiate crisis and some
people call it epidemic because is do
you see what the Sackler family did to
humanity for profit in the 90s and in
the 2000s crazy so that's the example of
what pharmaceutical companies all over
everything I know you would think at
this point people would realize oh that
family is demonic I'm not like a good
and evil kind of guy I'm not that binary
but when you see pharmaceutical
companies eradicating the population for
profit I gotta wonder if maybe they're
evil or doing
oxytocin it's supposed to be like a
feel-good chemical like oxide because
oxytocin is like I think that's why they
named it it's like the orgasm
manipulation tactics thing so you would
think people would be so awakened to the
pharmaceutical companies attempt at
profits that they would be eye-opening
and engaging at Pfizer right now like
with a microscope what's weird is they
came down so hard on Tobacco right but
they don't come down they like praise
the pharmaceutical industry for all that
they're doing for Humanity and the
pharmaceutical industry is getting all
this Federal funding
right you know hey burning burning
breathing and burning smoke is obviously
is bad for you so that's an easy target
paying up for that stuff with like all
the coveted tests and all that crap
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time